[Music]
we all want to see what it's like to be
in the loud house on Christmas Day the
Christmas episode gives us a pretty good
idea of how crazy it is but the episode
also reveals plenty of things you bet
you didn't even notice wait until you
hear which country totally banned it
give this video a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel let's
check out 10 secret facts in the loud
House Christmas episode you didn't know
about winter scenery we all know the
loud houses theme song right is one of
our favorite theme songs ever but have
you noticed what's different about it it
all starts the same Lincoln is crashing
through the crowded halls dodging girls
like ping pong balls just to reach the
bathroom on time guys gonna do what he
can to survive right okay enough of the
lyrics but have you noticed this
difference in the Christmas episode the
intro usually ends with Lily waddling by
everyone sitting on the living room sofa
and making her adorable noises but this
time the scenery suddenly changed into a
winter theme in the middle of Lily's
waddle but that's not all although it's
not explained why the colors are usually
red yellow and blue but for this
Christmas episode the creator's actually
decided to change the colors to
Christmas colors seems fitting doesn't
it you'll also notice that the theme
song changes to a Christmas Orchestra
version during the episode announcement
you can also hear the Christmas version
of the family's original song during the
end just as the Lana notes is her
twelfth Christmas pun we'll talk more
about that later do you prefer the
Christmas version of the theme song or
the original let us know in the comments
twelve tons of Christmas if you've
watched this episode you probably know
that LuAnn wanted to make her 12 puns
before Christmas and of course she
succeeded her puns might be cringy but
let's be honest we all get entertained
by them especially when she laughs the
most out of everyone in the family 12
puns of Christmas is of course upon
itself as it's a play on 12 days of
Christmas but have you managed to catch
every single pun LuAnn made here they
are in her first she says the lyrics
make no frankincense frankincense is one
of the gifts brought by Magi on
Christmas Day in her second pun she says
she only has to come up with 11 myrrh
not her best joke but myrrh was also one
of the gifts she also said chicken holly
bear her mom which is also a pretty bad
pun she also accuses Lily of stalking
her and says that her dad is getting
figgy with it then she says her dad will
have to ask
cows but instead of saying you will she
says you'll her number-9 pun involving
there's no time like the present and for
number 10 she says to just ribbon you xi
she mentions the Christmas spirit and in
the very last scene she wraps it all up
Oh LuAnn never change mister browses
secrets if you have a large family you
can fact that there's a grumpy old
neighbor somewhere in your neighborhood
who's really been happy about the chaos
in the loud house this wall definitely
belongs to mr. Krauss have you ever
noticed that his name wasn't officially
revealed until the 23rd episode of
season 1 and in season 2 we finally get
to know mr. grouse a little bit closer
but not only does it turn out that he
has a huge family he also calls Lincoln
by his name for the first time ever mr.
Kraus reminds us of old man Marley from
the very first home alone movie who has
a similar story and connection he's
equally as grumpy and at the end he also
slowly warms up to the boy that seems to
cause so much trouble in mr. grouses
case he goes right back to being angry
at Lincoln after his sledge breaks the
window of his house that is of course
totally understandable but we still love
the fact he finally calls and combines
actual name we're telling you this
episode is full of small iconic moments
you probably miss you have to stay tuned
to find some more facts including which
country decided to totally skip this
episode everyone is singing we have seen
the loud kids sing individually some
definitely more than others we're
looking at you Luna we're totally in
love with Lunas rockin style but we've
always wanted to see the entire loud
family sing in the Christmas special it
finally happened the loud family along
with several friends decide to bring
some holiday cheer to mr. grouses
Christmas by singing Christmas carols of
course those are done with Lena as a
lead because who else would be able to
do such an amazing job great job Luna
speaking of did you notice that the loud
parents hide their faces behind the
presents for the entire song mr. Kraus
was surprised by the carols but we were
definitely surprised by our next fact so
make sure you stay tuned to find out
what it is did you like their Christmas
song they really did make this the best
Christmas ever
who are you cartoons always seem to
avoid
the faces of kids parents from cow and
chicken to Tom and Jerry the creators
always wanted to add the kid magic to
cartoon shows well the loud house is
exactly the same we're not sure why the
official reveal actually happened in the
first place
nevertheless when Senor Ann read aloud
reveal their faces for the very first
time in this episode if you started
watching the loud house from season 2
this was probably never seen as a big
deal but we can imagine some of you were
shocked when you saw the two standing
there with the rest of the family ready
to celebrate Christmas with their
neighbors and if you never even noticed
we're here to tell you what it's true
their faces were first revealed in this
exact episode it's like a holiday
miracle and we're quite happy that their
faces remain unrevealed throughout the
second season as they both have their
moments that are definitely some of our
favorites
Lisa's emotions although most kids get
excited for Christmas it's an emotional
time for many we always hear about tons
of heartbreaking stories from those who
are less fortunate in the loud house
Christmas special mr. grouse was one of
those people
unlike the loud family which is huge and
they always have someone around mr.
grouse was all alone as his family was
far away another lot of people want to
be alone for Christmas out of all loud
children Lisa is quite the mystery we're
often left completely perplexed as to
why she needs certain things for her
experiment and sometimes she lets us in
on her personality we previously heard
that Lisa is impervious to human
emotions and she really doesn't seem to
do much of crying and laughing can you
believe it that she cries like a baby
after Lincoln finished his story about
mr. grouse to be fair we Craig - his
story was totally moving although seeing
Lisa actually tear up made us cry even
harder for Lisa it really is okay to cry
and let out your emotions especially
when you hear a sad story like mr.
browses Lola's personality the
six-year-old Lola is often seen as a
bratty pageant girl who always has to
get what she won otherwise she always
throws a fit out of all characters Lola
is the one that actually does act her
age because this behavior is pretty
typical for six-year-olds but what's not
typical is the reveal her personality
Lola
actually thinks that she's the sweetest
girl around let's be honest she can't
have her moments although for the
majority of the time we all know this
isn't true so in this episode Lola
revealed that she actually thinks she's
super sweet
we're not exactly surprised but did you
know that this kind of self delusion
Apocrypha has been compared to a Polish
play called the morality of mrs. dolkka
where the main adult character often
shows the same symptoms of course
they're much more extreme than Lola's
pretense to be kind to make it on st.
Nick's list well let's hope that Lola's
attitude is in fact just a phase that
she will grow to be kind without having
an agenda attached to her behavior do
you think she'll actually grow up to be
a complete diva presents have you ever
wondered what you'd give the loud kids
for Christmas this episode finally
reveals what each of the loud kids got
people like Lorri absolutely couldn't
hold the excitement of opening her
present but we can imagine that's how
most kids feel like on Christmas Eve but
the wait is finally over now Laurie and
the rest of you can finally find out
what the loud kids got for Christmas
Lincoln of course got a game system and
a replacement sled because he broke the
other one when he accidentally drove it
into mr. Crouse window Laurie got Bobby
and there's no surprise there
fashionista function ISA Lenny got new
shoes and Luna got an awesome banjo Lyn
got sports shoes she could become the
best at soccer Lucy got a bust of Edwin
because well she's Lucy Clara got a
dungeon playset and Lola got a castle
playset Lisa got a meteorite a book and
a photo of Santa to prove he exists and
Lily got a teddy bear to play with and
cuddle at night seems like those
presents match their personalities
pretty well right it's not the only
Christmas thing that's matching wait
until you hear the biggest Christmas
secret you'd never guess BAM in one
country did you know that one country
decided to not air the loud house
Christmas special if you watch the other
videos on the loud house you probably
know that there are a couple of
inappropriate scenes on the show that
had to be censored in countries like UK
but there are very rare episodes that
never actually got aired we couldn't
find any real reason why this happened
but it could be but it's because
Christmas isn't celebrated until January
in Russia well it's definitely strange
why the Nickelodeon Russia wouldn't show
this specific episode even though it
barely contains any innuendos the answer
might just be pretty simple Russia
celebrates Christmas on January 7th as
the church still uses the old Julian
calendar for any religious celebration
days since the loud house Christmas
special aired in mid-december for most
countries it could just be that they had
to decide to not air the episode to
stick to Russian customs speaking of
Russia there are nine loud house up
that never made it on air and they
include some of our favorites like L is
for love so if you managed to see every
single episode you should count yourself
lucky and that's it for our video for
more videos like this one check out five
TV shows that copied the loud house see
you next time
[Music]